[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if the ending
of euphoria laughter you dazed and
confused then prepare to trip out on my
theory for what happened in the finale
of the show
whether it was music to your ears or had
you afraid that Roux went on a relapse
the closing scenes left a lot to unpack
from them
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down exactly what I think happened at
the end of episode 8 and salt the earth
behind you and giving my theory on
whether rue is alive or not there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
seen you for you yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of euphoria season 1
euphoria mainly follows rue and Jules
who probably had one of the most fleshed
out relationships that we've seen on our
televisions for a good couple of years
especially with the series just being a
depa Souls long there's a lot of other
characters to talk about at the end but
for this video I just want to focus on
those two people and what happens to
them in the season finale ruined Jules
in the end come up with a plan to up and
move sticks and flee to a nearby town to
get away from their life however in what
is a really heartbreaking moment rue
backs out a bit last-minute and decides
to not step on the train with Jules
because she sees that she can't leave
her family ruse family have already been
through a lot and after losing her
father I believe that she takes
responsibility for her actions and
realizes that this would only add more
devastation to their mystery and now she
doesn't want to be there she realizes
that she has to in addition to this I
also think rue finally realizes that in
her relationship with Jules there comes
a lot of toxicity and she must break
away from this cycle in removing Jules
she will actually be able to finally
focus fully on her family though that
doesn't mean that she's fully gotten rid
of all of it
this devolves into her walking home
crying and we get flashes of some of her
happiest and ugliest memories we finally
learn that Rouge red hoodie actually
belonged to her father and that
everything that has happened to her has
pretty much been driven by his death I'm
sure many of you watching this have been
in similar situations when losing
someone where you hold on to some item
of clothing or object that the deceased
person owned as a way to remember them
and hopefully keep them in your life
with the death of a loved one there's
always one of two ways you can go either
it strengthens you or we can see you and
unfortunately we see in the clothes that
rue goes with the latter breaking her
sobriety and relapsing from here we get
a music video set to the song all of us
by labyrinth which zendaya herself sings
it's a really haunting piece that
indicates several things about the
character the feeling of being high can
often leave you thinking that you were
in a music video and somehow things
around you may not quite be reality
which it becomes clear that rooh is
experiencing reddit user you look so
sexy Lisa I don't make the names up said
the following when discussing ruse
experience of this
I doubt rude pretty much all of the time
she's an unreliable narrator but rather
than as a writing prop I think she's
unreliable because she's an addict and
addicts Elias sauce I'm one but I think
in that moment when she relapses we see
the euphoria she experiences her dad is
alive she's loving on the family is
singing and you're dancing and there's a
choir personally I don't hear a choir
when I'm effed up but I am 100% a star
in my own music video so I think that's
rather accurate I thought it was an
insanely in a bit of way to betray the
feeling of a high so it seems like
though she is treating this like a
reality it doesn't mean that this is how
it's playing out but the finale of the
video the people around her in the song
form a hill with one another which real
climbs up and jumps into the sky from
waltz have seen a large handful of
people take this as meaning that the
characters overdosed and this was her
brain living out of fantasy which is
backed up by the fact that during the
video she hooks her family as if to say
goodbye the lyrics of the song itself
indicates something different which
comes in the line into that good night
which is a reference of the poem do not
go gentle into that good night
which I'm sure many of you have heard
those who know the poem will understand
that it's actually about fighting
against death which I think this ending
actually summarizes rue escapes from the
darkness and into the light which to me
sums up that the relapse has helped the
clear hair slightly of all her troubles
in life and she will attack things from
a new perspective in regards to her
family I get the feeling that she's
forgiven them and in the end her choice
of them over jewels signifies to me that
she is now moving on completely and away
from that toxic situation that doesn't
mean life is easy though and similar to
the rest of us who still makes mistakes
and has to battle her addiction even
when she's taking a positive step
forward which solidifies just how
complex that euphoria is even when we're
moving forward there are still things
that can pull us off track and one
moment of weakness can undo months of
hard work which happens in the case of
rue there's also the fact that zendaya
recently posted on Twitter that she just
got the call from HBO that the show was
being renewed so it seems that they are
indeed keeping her around and in the
loop which cements my theory this is due
to be released in 2020 and I believe it
will pick up with ruh coming down from
this high and potentially backtracking
on her stance on jewels similar to the
way that she backtracked on her sobriety
however the second season will focus on
her recognizing in her sob that this is
still wrong and therefore moving on from
it but without the relapse there's
obviously a lot to unpack from the show
and even without Roos season 2 is set up
to be something special
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale and if you think Bru is
alive or dead comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the recent eight
minutes of it chapter 2 that was
released in cinemas over the weekend it
covers everything you need to know about
the scene so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just want to let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of Avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on euphoria in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray
be shipped out from then whoever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definitions thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time
take care peace